[Music]
you guys ready for some YouTube drama
yeah Oh give it to Matt what you're not
that you're a motorcycle helmet not
celebrate sit or whatever yeah the Tata
set of motorcycles do calibrates I don't
know the proper thing is puff a hairline
crack she's a defibrillator
what anyway you too drama so we are
talking about Colleen ballinger who's
that who's that Miranda sings oh the
girl with the lipid speak in the that
her other name I mean it's the real
person so Colleen is her real name and
Miranda as a character so what happened
to her Miranda her character their
character like Uncle Sam Uncle 10 we
render singular character
sorry it was like oh okay so the drama
surrounding her right now is it's
watching it - mm-hmm you want some of
the drama yeah he's like drama
okay so there's a lot of accusation and
like claims like drama things that are
happening here some of them is that 14
years ago or one of them is 14 years ago
when she was a teenager
her and her sister made this video where
they dressed as Latinas and did some
brown face brown face stuff and actually
didn't see this video but here's a
screenshot that looks [ __ ] ridiculous
dude yeah so this is one of them another
one is where she she had talked about
when she was three years old she like
pinched a dog or something the dog
reacted bit her and like they had to put
the dog down because of that because of
the fact that it fit all in the face it
bit her on her face and so she has felt
very guilty for about that but in this
one particular video she talked about
that experience again very
lightheartedly where she was like I had
to murder my own dog or something and
then people took that clip and like ran
with it
yeah and then so that's those are some
of the the scandals happening but then
the major one here is this kid named
Adam he's 17 years old he said that ever
since he was 13 I believed like he has
been a major like Miranda sings fan and
like so much so that how does he know
you said he's 17 so I've been four years
yeah
that's not that long yeah we have JK
fans that's been with us for over 10
years so what's up you ain't no real fan
I'm your biggest fan watching for four
years would you be like what the [ __ ] I
mean depends I take the love and I
thought thank you so much that's not the
point but like do you like me more than
to pocket if they say yeah I'm like
that's a big fan what if they say whoo
oh that's even bigger well I'll be like
oh why do you like me more than that mr.
Takashi 69 and then they'll be like hell
yeah and I'd be like I could damn you
set the bar so low but you know his
random people a hundred [ __ ] hundred
million in like two days yeah because
they wanted to hear him [ __ ] yeah cuz
he's a snitch exactly exactly so what
happened to this guy in the car leans
okay meek song didn't even come out that
hard the relationship with Adam and
Colleen so many many years ago when he
started or four years ago not that long
ago when he started being a fan they
like he would go to her shows and meet
her in person cuz he's from I believe
Ireland and so whenever she was out
there like he would go to her shows and
like he was very active on like her fan
accounts and on Twitter to the point
where it grabbed her attention and then
during this one particular livestream
where she decided to open up a box of
forever 21 ugly clothes that she bought
with her best friend Korey they were
doing this live stream and during the
live stream she liked Corey's a guy of
course yeah okay so he they usually send
things to pent like she usually sends
stuff to fans so there was this
particular lingerie set and apparently
like Adam made her laugh during this
live stream so she's like oh my god I
guys
something like what imagine if I send in
this or whatever like much bodies
parents are gonna be so upset and like
what the [ __ ]
so they joked about it during the
livestream like a long time goes by she
doesn't send him the lingerie but then
they see each other in person and she's
like oh I still got to send it to you
eventually she does send it to him
his parents grab the package right out
of his hands cuz they're like who the
[ __ ] is sending you lingerie you know
you're a kid so that is [ __ ] yeah so
then it's pretty bad just gonna dumb it
oh really
well it's a joke right thirty year-old
woman sending lingerie in a child thank
you text and they're seventeen is
contact is a video of course context is
important but just with no context
isolate the parents out like blindly
yeah and the problem the parents aren't
using proper communication Wow like
going hey what is this oh it's part of a
video let me see the video oh I just
think that's weird well that's the thing
so according to Colleen side of the
story she always felt like that his mom
loved her and was super supportive cuz a
lot of times Adam would tweet out like
how she's like another huge Miranda
sings fan and like that they loved that
she loved that she would that called
Hollywood speak to Adam and she was a
proud mom for all those reasons and so
that's why she continued to interact
with Adam because she was like okay cool
your mom approves I was like this is
like you know the context of things like
it should be fine but not like in Adams
video he pulls it out and he's just like
yeah my parents very upset you think
this is a way to [ __ ] fire at her so
you could get views dude what the [ __ ]
it kept the [ __ ] for like all this no I
don't think why would they keep it he's
a fan that's how I feel like the
suspicious side of me is like this seems
like he just wants to make a video I
mean I don't know the rest yet also but
why would okay like your unboxing you
like damn this is ugly right and then
while the context of the video so she's
known for doing weird [ __ ] like that
yeah show by stuff and then she's like
what's the weird [ __ ] I got this time
and then they talk about it and then
she'll give just she'll give all that
[ __ ] away regardless of
to send them out yeah she's just like
okay what fans gonna get it this time
okay cool here you go you're gonna get
this [ __ ] lava lamp today oh yeah
yeah yeah so it's not it's a it's like
they they act like they sent him a dildo
so that's the context been that whole
the situation but then for mandolin
what's the scandal is that like that's
what's making headlines is like Miranda
like Colleen ballinger sends lingerie to
a thirteen-year-old like that's already
this gay headline okay that's why it's
talking about that's kind of weird
yeah so then Adam goes into this more
into their their friendship relationship
over the past years and he said that in
the beginning like when she was getting
divorced from her first husband that
apparently she told this little kid all
these super mega personal details about
the divorce Wow nation ship to the point
where she according to Adam she would
she would convince him to go out and
find like dig up dirt about the ex and
about it does he have Wow receipts where
the receipt he didn't post any reason he
says he has them and so does she so I
say if you're gonna tell a story post
the receipts with the story or don't
tell the story he was saying that he
didn't want to because it's like
personal errand see that that that even
motive because what ends up happening is
now it seems like he's doing it for
publicity yeah I don't want to like [ __ ]
up a person life but let me tell you all
this [ __ ] but let me [ __ ] her personal
life okay well let me tell you so in
Adams eyes the thing that really like
took a turn and there are no longer
friends is because she after he made me
famous we're not friends anymore is that
what he see no so this is the the story
that happens here so okay so Miranda
sings Twitter was dying down and he Adam
comes in and tells Colleen like hey I
have so many ideas like for you to post
like I photoshopped all these images or
whatever like hear the jokes at Miranda
could post and she ends up giving him
the green light
to a point where she tells him like okay
I'm gonna do this like trial run with
you and if this goes well you'll be my
social media manager and like you can
handle a social media and stuff so he
ended up sending her like 15 things that
he was gonna be posting and then she
ends up giving him her Twitter login
that's tight and then he ends up posting
this one joke where Miranda sings comes
out as a Meghan Trainor fan which is
like a lot of people I immediately
attacked Miranda sings because it's like
this is gay baiting like why are you
using like you know come me like coming
out for a gay person is very like sacred
an important moment in their lives so
this is like really disrespectful
because you use the term coming out for
Meghan Trainor right oh so then a lot of
people have started giving her hate for
that and then so Colleen in turn starts
telling Adam like oh my god like this is
crazy
things are getting insane I'm really
really really upset I like I'm really
sensitive about this whatever but you
did a great job I love the stuff that
you did and all this stuff so like heat
for him and his eyes he got mixing mix
mixed signals here and like very
confusing contradicting things from
Miranda or Colleen and then so he ended
up taking it really really hard to the
point where he felt that she was making
him feel guilty for the backlash so he
was he was explaining how that whole day
was just like ruined and like all this
stuff and and but then on Colleen side
cuz she ends up making a whole video
about this saying like I never once
place blame on him because this kid ends
up posting like screenshots or their
conversation too so to me personally it
doesn't seem like she's blaming him at
all but he just took it really hard and
he's 17 right right how many followers
does he have like and his YouTube feels
like 22 K when I saw till then the part
that really hurt them the most is that
Corey ends up going into a like fan
group chat damn thing and he ends up
saying to this group like hey Colleen
thinks this is Adam pretending to be
this person talking [ __ ] about Colleen
online
and then that's when Adam felt really
hurt like why would I do that [ __ ] I
thought we were friends and then that's
when he like cut ties and stuff but then
he's so a lot of people are coming at
Colleen saying that she's a groomer and
that she's like manipulative uses her
child bands for for digging up social
media all that all this stuff she's
getting like rekt wow that's not like a
drama man well I don't know anything
about this stuff I just thought that she
made interesting character comedy and I
didn't know that like she actually
worked with their fans like that that
are underage I think that's the danger
it's like any any workplace a lot of
places don't hire kids that are underage
because of this reason yeah when they
call them social media manager I just
assumed because I assumed he just got
paid to like that's a real job we're
like 17 you need a work permit I think
under the age of under the age of like
13 right so no 16-under understandings
of you're 15 and under but now he's
admitting legal for like two years but
yeah I just assumed he got all that
paperwork done and then like I don't
know she was explaining in her video how
like for anyone that she hires like
there is like a like an audition kind of
yeah which makes sense yeah so this was
his like audition thing and then it just
blew up because of the whole gay baiting
thing so in her in her video it sounded
like I don't I don't know I didn't
really watch much of her stuff so I
wouldn't call myself a fan um I know of
her just cuz we've been on YouTube for
so long but in her video she like fest
up to everything she was like when you
know the 14 that video like that was so
racist of me like I didn't know better
at the time but it was stupid I did [ __ ]
up it is racist it is bad I feel like
it's such a random tangent on to the
original problem though uh but I mean
that's what everyone's attacking her for
so just he's just trying to address
everything you know and then the one
after that what was the other one the
dog oh the dog one yeah that one too
she's just saying how like yeah like I
guess according to the state like they
had to do it because of the answer
when she like dug her nails into him or
something like that so she was
apologizing for that and then with the
whole like just her explanation like she
just took all the blame where she needed
to and it didn't sound like she was
trying to like wiggle her way out of it
and make herself so nah she was like
yeah I was stupid I really [ __ ] up you
know in retrospect I should have never
sent this [ __ ] to a thirteen-year-old
I [ __ ] up there she was like really
fasting to like all of it we're all like
[ __ ] that's pretty big was a good
apology I thought it was you think
she'll win a Streamy for the 2020s best
apology video should be its own category
I'm kind of pissed because 2019 I feel
like I should have won the best breakup
video but [ __ ] David orbic had a bug
a breakup the same year and they had way
more views I know dudes so cute are way
bigger two together animal [ __ ] man but
I agree I mean that was really good [ __ ]
you Nadeem ours was way better I think
the problem with these like small
businesses like youtubers and stuff is
that you don't have a whole legal team
to like clear everything you do like big
businesses so like everyone's just like
oh I think this is fine this will be
fine that's pretty fine until something
blows up and it's like oh [ __ ] I didn't
know this could turn out like this yeah
it's just such a scary time for
youtubers I guess cuz I'm like listening
to all of it I'm like yeah it's drama
but for people to come at her like crazy
as if like she had illegal dogfighting
in her backyard or like majority of her
fan base is like from 12 to like 18 like
so so they don't understand the legality
or professionalism and all these other
things they're just going after hearsay
and it's just high school yeah it's just
so scary I'm interacting with my fans
it's really nice like they want to talk
to me and I talk back to them yeah I
send them [ __ ] like random [ __ ] from my
videos yeah the stuff that was weird
that was just talking about your
relationship with the 13 year old like
calling in a relationship - I mean I
don't know anything about the situation
granted right but it's like if she just
responding to some DMS or is she like
relationship right I mean to the point
where he's over here digging up dirt
about her ex like that's [ __ ] weird
I would be I want to
through divorce with a child some [ __ ]
cuz she'll dig up stuff being in Ireland
she kept going on like the tea sites or
whatever like the gossip gossip yeah she
could do it on her own or whatever I
don't know she's trying to use his time
you all the time and over her own yeah
it's really strange but she did receive
a lot of positive feedback in her
apology video so it seems like people
are like and to me like relationships
are a two-way street so like yeah it's
weird but also like he must have been
very on the tee or in the gossip - or
maybe where she's a fan maybe he was
like oh yeah I'll find it for you that's
why he brought up the word grooming
exactly like sex he groomed her no room
Tamil by him being a fan be like using
like using her power yeah as an
authority oh I see cuz he's like smitten
she's abusing the power here be a good
little tile hotel for mommy pretty much
if it's true yeah yeah she didn't
address any of that in her video but I I
noticed so I don't know she address
everything else oh man she should just
be like [ __ ] y'all
none of this [ __ ] can cancel me [ __ ]
that would for sure cancel her and this
day and age that that response in the
90s it's like dance was gangstas awhile
you like a more yeah it's like Snoop
Dogg murder was the case that they gave
me
[Music]
[Music]